[Music]
Warner Brothers dropped the first teaser
trailer for director Todd Phillips his
Joker movie on Wednesday April 3rd and
the internet went nuts as fans sparked a
fiery debate over which actor might be
the better Joker
The Dark Knight's Heath Ledger or the
brand-new Clown Prince of Crime Joaquin
Phoenix
when it comes to the Joker everyone has
their favorite version some prefer Cesar
Romero's portrayal of the character on
the 1960s Batman television series
others think the 1980s brought the best
ever interpretation of mr. J by Jack
Nicholson who played the Joker in Tim
Burton's Batman film do I look like I'm
joking a fair few out there are a little
more radical preferring Jared Leto's
silver tooth tattooed take on the Joker
in Suicide Squad bring the car
I'll go for a drive and some people
think the live-action versions of the
infamous character pale in comparison to
Mark Hamill's voiceover work but it's
the late Heath Ledger who probably
captivates audiences the most why so
serious to this day many fans still
believe no one can even come close to
his stunning turn as the Joker in
Christopher Nolan's The Dark Knight
however now there's a new Joker in town
Joaquin Phoenix's Arthur Fleck the
aspiring comedian who experiences a
psychotic break and becomes the Joker
unsurprisingly social media and numerous
entertainment sites have been weighing
in on which actor may end up reigning
the best Joker
shortly after watching the footage of
director Todd Phillips as Joker one fan
took to Twitter to say that Phoenix
would be the best Joker we've ever seen
another fan wrote that Phoenix is coming
for Heath Ledger's crown as the best
Joker one Twitter user was so blown away
by seeing Phoenix and character that
they placed an early bet on the outcome
of the film calling it now Joaquin
Phoenix is going to be the best
live-action Joker many fans were quick
to bring up Ledger's performance for
direct comparison with one Twitter user
writing I have a great feeling that
Joaquin Phoenix's Joker is gonna be
better than Heath Ledger's Jamel Hill a
staff writer for The Atlantic feels like
Phoenix might end up turning in a better
performance I didn't think it was
possible for anyone to play The Joker
better than Heath Ledger but Joaquin
Phoenix looks like he's got a shot Tia
Fabi of geek vibes nation wrote an
opinion piece about why Phoenix will
probably go down as one of the best
Joker's in history writing apart this is
a different rendition than what we have
gotten before and it's going to be Oscar
worthy mark my words
meanwhile one fan was evidently prepared
to turn the online debate into a
real-life battle Heath Ledger will never
be replaced
as the best Joker fight me writer George
M Johnson wrote that people should quote
let the Joker rest with the best that
did it that's clearly a reference to
Ledger who passed away in 2008 at the
age of 28 Advocate April rain later
responded to Johnson's tweet writing
this is my thought as well why anyone
would even attempt this after Heath is
beyond
me clearly passionate about all things
Joker professional Fortnite player Nate
Hill tweeted Heath Ledger's Joker was so
good the character should be retired I
will compare every Joker to Heath and
they will always fall short the debate
was just as hardcore over Instagram one
individual wrote that Ledger is the best
Joker and that quote anarchist Joker
will always be my favorite another
argued Heath set the bar but Phoenix is
one of the best actors out there and his
Joker can be iconic as well
some fans simply refused to choose a
favorite Joker and instead argued that
comparison simply can't be made as the
actors appear to be playing different
iterations of the classic character
while Keane is portraying the early
developments of the Joker character
Heath Ledger is the developed character
in the years following silly to compare
the two another fan basically asked the
internet to stop being the Internet can
we stop comparing who did this character
best please online fandom is just taking
the fun out of everything I swear one
Twitter user actually made a good point
Heath Ledger and Joaquin Phoenix were
friends so how about we stop with the
extreme comparisons of their Joker
performances it's disrespectful and
tasteless it goes without saying that
these are just a few selections out of
the thousands of responses fans posted
after seeing the Joker teaser and
opinions are bound to change as the film
nears its release date and after we all
finally get to watch the thing whether
you're a fan of Phoenix a longtime
ledger lover or someone who still
doesn't want to pick sides try to keep
an open mind about Joker and try not to
get into any social media fights Joker
will tumble into theaters on October 4th
2019 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about DC EU movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]